l'opération de bon dimanche bonjour
daniel bon pourquoi d'abord avoir décidé
d'éliminer les tickets libéral comme ça
bon on est perçu ce soit avec mes
chances et on est à + bienvenue dans le
parti libéral comme si on avait été
expulsé de joe 5 et mais la raison pour
laquelle on l'a on est demeuré cycle
avec la loi pas la loi du parlement
si les libéraux avaient perdu le pouvoir
et les consommateurs étaient gagnants
nous aurions été reconnu comme étant le
seul parti d'opposition au sénat donc on
a gardé l'étiquette libérale à cause de
cette raison là les choses se sont
précipitées quand la semaine dernière
une douzaine de députés indépendants
sénateur indépendant et consommateurs
qui ont formé le caucus des sénateurs
canadiens et ça nous a obligé ça nous a
forcé à faire notre changement un peu
précipité on avait l'intention c'est a
réglé depuis longtemps qu'on change de
nom et qu'on allait se rendent un peu
plus accessible aux députés ou sénateurs
indépendants en n'ayant pu l'étiquette
libérale mais plusieurs de ces sénateurs
l'occasion sous leurs appels
téléphoniques de monsieur trudeau qui se
sont fait dire on compte sur vous pour
être sénateur indépendant
donc il ne pouvait pas se joindre au
caucus libéral
on espère que c'est un secret de
polichinelle que certains d'entre eux
sont plus progressiste que les douze qui
sont devenus des consommateurs
soudain nous tenons au sénat vont se
joindre à nous mais qui se joindre nous
non nous avons décidé que l'on changé de
nom et qu'on s'identifie comme on est
effectivement on n'est pas devenu
progressiste la semaine passée on l'a
toujours été
alors maintenant vous êtes l'opposition
vous êtes un parti progressiste vous
êtes un caucus progressistes au sein du
haut saint du chenet et là l'idée c'est
d'aller chercher des sénateurs
indépendants vous aimeriez qu'il y en a
qui joignent à vous on espère qu'à
l'intérieur du caucus des sénateurs
indépendants qui nous disait on peut pas
se joindre à vous parce que vous êtes
trop identifié au parti libéral
si vous changez n'ont peut-être qu'on me
se joindre vous ya déjà dix est
interdépendant qui vous il ya un homme
plusieurs avec qui on eu des
conversations
s'ils viennent pour on va être quand
même le caucus progressistes au sénat
s'il vient ça va tout simplement
augmenter notre notre nombre est assurée
puisque fo soyons bien honnête notre
statut de reconnaissance est basé sur un
nombre minimum de sénateur et après un
certain temps qu'il y avait de mes
collègues qui vont prendre leur retraite
on risque de ne pas être reconnus qui
est donc l'idée là dedans c'est parce
qu'on a des retraites qui s'en viennent
au sein du caucus ou de l'ancienne
caisse libérale ni d adam s'est assurée
que vous êtes vous êtes séduisant pour
certains sénateurs indépendants que vous
gardez les produits non la pérennité la
pérennité de 2,2 d'avoir d'abord au
sénat mais tant qu'il y a 2 caucus
conservateur au sénat inquiet le caucus
des sénateurs officiel d'opposition
l'autre qui est un caucus formés que
deux sénateurs conservateurs on peut pas
laisser juste un caucus de ses nattes de
sénateurs progressistes qui sont les
indépendants
on veut être reconnu comme étant l'un
des deux caucus qui va être capable de
défendre les positions idéologiques qui
sont représentés à la chambre la chambre
des communes est formée majoritairement
de parlementaires progressistes npd
bloquistes libéraux
on veut que la même chose soit reconnu
au sénat ça c'est évidemment y est paris
là dedans parce que si elle les
indépendants se joignent pas vous vous
perdez votre influence au fur et mesure
où les gens de votre cuche prennent leur
retraite
on perd pas de pertes on perd notre
influence on ne perd pas notre
pertinence il y avait toujours de la
place pour un caucus progressistes au
sénat on a eu l'occasion de s'entretenir
et quelques semaines avec le sénateur
andré pratique qui déplorait la
partisanerie au sénat il l est la
présence toujours très forte du côté
très partisan ce que vous venez pas
alimenter de critiques la seule la seule
partisanerie qui avait au sénat depuis
les quatre dernières années depuis le 7
à celle des comptes les consommateurs
les consommateurs le mercredi matin vos
caucus du parti consommateurs nationale
et il arrive au sénat conservateur
nous on ne siègera pas au la
partisanerie n'est résident a pas de ce
côté ci de là du sénat les ide est
uniquement du côté consommateurs
il doit y avoir une réforme du sénat il
doit y avoir une modification à la
réglementation pour permettre justement
de reconnaître les indépendants des
groupes qui ne sont pas nécessairement
conservateurs ou libéraux à quel point
est-ce que c'est urgent que ce soit fait
le message le plus important de cette
semaine c'est de dire au premier
ministre trudeau
vous nous aviez vous nous avez créé vous
avez créé un nouveau sénat faut
maintenant que la législation
reconnaissent ce nouveau sénat la loi du
parlement telle qu'elle est écrite ne
reconnaît pas le statut d'un sénat avec
la seule chose qui est reconnu au sénat
selon les mots du parlement c'est le
parti d'opposition consommateurs lorsque
les indépendants ne sont pas reconnus
selon la loi et dieu sait que les
progressistes non plus on va mettre
beaucoup de pression premier ministre
pour dire vous avez promis pendant la
campagne électorale monsieur trudeau de
réformer la loi parlementaire
on compte sur vous pour le faire le plus
tôt possible parce que si vous voulez
réussir votre pari de réformer ces n'en
faut que vous réformer la loi du temps
pour que les gens comprennent si c'est
pas fait là ça veut dire qu'il ya aussi
un changement gouvernement les
indépendants et les progressistes
perdent à peu près toute marge de
manoeuvre à la chambre suis très
optimiste que les libéraux en est au
pouvoir pendant les prochaines années
donc c'est une question hypothétique
mais la réalité c'est qu'il n'y a plus
maintenant automatiquement un parti
d'opposition si jamais les consommateurs
prennent le pouvoir
on pense que ce serait important que la
pression soit mis sous le premier
ministre pour que il les réformes là
loin pour que ce problème le soin
problème hypothétique sénateurs garçonne
vous l'avez mentionné en début
d'entrevue il ya d'autres cas que ciel
caucus et sénateur de l'oise et les
conservateurs y avoue ya les
indépendants comment est ce que vous
voyez ce sénat la fonctionner de façon
saine et façon coordonnée avec autant de
voix qui vont dans plusieurs directions
ça fait quinze ans que chaussée non état
dans le modèle traditionnel quand je
suis arrivé il y avait des libéraux des
consommateurs et quelques indépendants
et l'arrivée des sénateurs indépendants
est un énorme progrès je pense que c'est
une très bonne chose
sauf qu'il faut que la législation
suivent la volonté du premier ménès
c'est un peu cacophonique puis je peux
comprendre mon ami andré pratte de ne
pas être heureux mais je pense que s'ils
avaient un peu plus patient il ya ce
sera perçu qu'à long terme
ce nouveau sénat indépendant va avoir
beaucoup plus d'efficacité que l'anci et
gmail l'ancien principe je croyais que
il y avait de la place dans le caucus
libéral pour des sénateurs je pense
qu'elle a fait le meilleur gouvernement
sont avait été autour de la table mais
c'est fait c'est réglé on tournerait pur
ma pole à la pâte à dent sud s'est réglé
faut maintenant que le la législation
suivent la volonté du premier ministre
monsieur dassault monsieur pratte disait
il y en a encore de la partie sonnerie
puis on encore de la pression du
gouvernement puis ça finit par faire en
sorte que même si on est indépendants
ont fini par appuyer le gouvernement
parce qu'on n'a pas les coudées franches
la légitimité à quel point ce que le
sénat est dépendant est vraiment
indépendant daniel moi si je suis l'un
des rares sénateurs qui a eu le plaisir
de siéger dans les deux chambres
j'étais député en et sénateurs pour moi
la chambre haute ces pôles du sénat
c'est la chambre des députés et que on
accepte que le sénat soit est inférieure
à la chambre des communes ce qui a
frustré plusieurs de mes collègues
indépendant c'est que après qu'on ait
asseyez d'amendé des projets du moins si
les élus décident que nos amendements ne
sont pas acceptables
je m'excuse la chambre des communes le
droit de refuser des amendements mais il
ya eu plus d'amendements dans les quatre
dernières années à des lois du parlement
qu'il y en eût dans les dix années
précédentes donc le système ils
fonctionnent que certaines personnes
aient eu des frustrations
j'accepte moi je pense que c'est un pas
dans la bonne direction
j'espère que la création de ce caucus
progressiste va être un autre pas dans
la bonne direction mais avant tout
j'espère que le premier ministre va
respecter ses engagements
c'est pas une priorité pour le
gouvernement ce qu'on peut comprendre ça
et ça va être compliqué dans un
gouvernement minoritaire
mais s'ils veulent que leur voix passe
bien au sénat qui nous donne les outils
proviendrait
ces métadonnées station merci beaucoup
merci il ya lien